فتره عيدي الميلاد وراس السنه هي الاكثر
تكلفه بالنسبه للكثيرين وهؤلاء المتبعون
يفكرون في انفاقهم وكيفيه التعامل مع
مواردهم الماليه بمسؤوليه في خضم غلاء
المعيشه المرتفع عند شراء الهدايا
تحذر جدا في نفقتها هذا العام واخترت
المجيئه الى المتاجر لانها اكثر حيويه
بدلا من التسوق عبر الانترنت
المبهره بحسب الامكانيات الفنيه والماديه
خصوصا مع غلاء المعيشه وارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه
في هذا الشرعي اعتدى سكانه المنافسه
لاظهار افضل زينه الاضواء هذا العام و
بسبب اسعار الطاقه المكلفه تجنبت اسر زينه
الاضواء فيما اخرون وصلوا على التقليدهم
باستخدام مصابيح اقل استهلاكا للكهرباء
لجمع التبرعات
واخرون في تكلفه تزيين منازلنا في هذا
الشارع هذا العام وهناك من لم يزين منزله
ولكن هذه تقاليد عيد الميلاد
الاضواء الرائعه هذه تجذب الزوار من مناطق
عده
»
لمواجهه التكلفه المعيشه اضافه الى اسعار
الطاقه دفعت بلديات وجمعيات التجار باضاءه
اضواء عيد الميلاد ثمان ساعات بدلا من 24
ساعه لتوفير استهلاك الكهرباء هذه الاضواء
كانت تستقطب المتسوقين كعادتها لكن
انفاقهم هو اقل بكثير من الاعوام الماضيه
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن